what's going on people I whipped out my
Heisenberg meeting because I've been
doing a re-watch of breaking back
because like many of you it's my
favorite show of all time and like many
of you I love catching a good editing
mistake now people have done videos and
articles on inaccuracies or editing
mistakes and Breaking Bad before but I
haven't seen anyone do a video about
this one yet and I know I cannot be the
only one who has ever noticed this so
spoilers ahead for people who haven't
seen breaking bad so at the end of
season two Jesse falls in love with a
woman named Jane and then Jane
unfortunately dies Jesse calls up Walt
Waltz calls up Saul Saul calls Mike and
is the first time we ever meet Mike and
Mike is brought in there to clean up the
crime scene because Jane's dead body is
in Jesse's apartment I'm gonna show you
guys a quick little few seconds here and
tell me if you notice it
foreign
did you catch it did you catch it let me
play it again let me play it again so
keep watching keep watching it oh my God
the Jane blinks her dead body blinks now
to me this is a massive massive mistake
Jane's death is one of the most
Monumental moments of the entire Series
so when you're in the editing room you
got to make sure your dead body isn't
blinking at all and I'm really surprised
the editors would choose this moment
unless of course it wasn't an editing
mistake and it was a way to clueless in
that Mike was actually brought in there
to finish the job no it's definitely an
entity mistake it's 100 enemy mistake